transmettre son savoir faire sa culture
un héritage que l'on legs pour encadrer
dès ses 12 ans emmanuel a été initié à
la sculpture par étapes en commençant
par le moulin mailly le comédien sera le
maillet bien bien voulu transpire -
c'est vrai qu'elle a repris le flambeau
fait
les schémas montois de faire revivre ça
qu'on voit ça les personnes qu il
connaît pas en fait
corinne et ses enfants se sont retrouvés
ici par le pur hasard
les cours de musique du samedi ont été
remplacés par des cours plus manuel très
sage avec des feuilles de coco ça fait
longtemps que l'atelier de 13 dont la
culture tamoule passe aussi par le
dessin cela fait une vingtaine d'années
que vela y pratique la calligraphie
un art qu'il essaye de transmettre
aujourd'hui n'existe pas et pour en
mettre plein les yeux nadine a ramené
pour l'occasion c'est plus beau sari
certains en coton en provenance du
kerala où d'autres plus scintillant
assassin fini la semaine créole
un moment de partage et de transmission
des plus belle tradition ancrée dans le
patrimoine réunionnais